encuentra las coordenadas del punto b
que es sobre el segmento base tal que
ave es dos séptimos de hace muy bien
entonces nos dan este segmento base y
que de hecho sería muy bueno ir viendo
qué coordenadas tienen estos puntos el
punto se tiene coordenadas 7,23 verdad
7,3 mientras que el punto a tiene
coordenadas menos siete coma menos
cuatro muy bien entonces tenemos este
segmento y nos dicen que encontremos un
punto b sobre este segmento tal que ave
sea dos séptimos de todo este segmento
completo entonces vamos a ver esto
geométricamente digamos voy a recrear
esto tenemos el segmento ave perdón hace
hace ahí tienen el segmento y vamos a
tener por ejemplo aquí el punto b el
punto b que es lo que debe cumplir este
punto b por ejemplo si esta distancia le
llamamos x lo que cumple esta otra
distancia es que sea dos séptimos de
toda la distancia completa muy bien o en
otras palabras lo que lo que tendríamos
es que la longitud de ave sea igual a
dos séptimos de la longitud de hace muy
bien y bueno tú dirás esto a lo mejor
sería
esto esto a lo mejor se resuelve si
calculamos la distancia de hace con la
fórmula del teorema de pitágoras
esencialmente y después dividimos entre
7 y multiplicamos por 2 para saber
cuánto debe ser esta distancia y luego
ajustar las coordenadas y eso podría ser
una forma de resolverlo sin embargo
calcular distancias y demás en este
contexto puede ser bastante complicado y
engorroso así que lo que vamos a hacer
es lo siguiente vamos a tomar este
segmento y vamos a partirlo en dos
problemas vamos a tener esta bueno vamos
a tener esta longitud y esta otra
longitud que es esencialmente la
horizontal y la vertical y lo que vamos
a hacer es que cada una de estas de
estas distancias la vamos a partir de
tal suerte que esto sea 2 séptimos de
toda esta completa y acá va a ser
este punto tal que es este pequeño
segmento o sea dos séptimos de todo esto
muy bien si hacemos esto entonces
habremos encontrado las coordenadas de
ve muy bien entonces vamos a hacerlo
tenemos aquí esta longitud esta longitud
horizontal de cuánto es bueno tenemos
menos 7 y tenemos que llegar a 7
entonces aumentamos 14 muy bien uno
puede simplemente pensarlo como 7 menos
menos 7 verdad tenemos este 7 y le
restamos menos 7 que son 14 muy bien
ahora cómo hacemos para obtener la
distancia vertical
entonces esta tenemos tres menos menos
cuatro que son tres cuatro y esto es
siete muy bien entonces tenemos 14 en la
distancia horizontal y 7 en la distancia
vertical ahora si nosotros dividimos 14
entre 7 y multiplicamos por 2 es decir
dos séptimos de 14 los séptimos de 14 es
2 por 14 son 28 entre 7 son cuatro es 4
muy bien entonces esta distancia de 14
en realidad me tengo que fijar en 4
muy bien ahí está el 4 y ahora de 7 si
calculamos dos séptimos de 7 pues eso es
2 verdad un séptimo de 7 es 1 y si
multiplicamos por 2 son 2 entonces ahí
lo tenemos tenemos que el punto debe
estar aquí
y respecto a la distancia horizontal
debe estar aquí así que las coordenadas
de este es nuestro punto b y tiene como
coordenadas menos 3 verdad menos 1 - 2 -
3 y de altura es menos 2
-2 muy bien y ahí tienen ustedes la
coordenada de be que esencialmente fue
mucho más fácil calcularlo de esta forma
que si hubiéramos intentado aproximarnos
por las distancias y después de ajustar
coordenadas de alguna forma muy rara así
que esta es una buena forma de resolver
este tipo de problemas